buoni
gli facciamo bene
allora assistiamo transit e pingui dopo
una settimana è vero non lo faccio più
tutte le settimane per ogni tanto ci sta
col ha giocato in a è più iscritti
toglie proprio
intestino imporsi wall jump let's go my
brother
mettiamo l'audio che dite comunque
ragazzi dagli scorsi episodi abbiamo
effettivamente appurato che personaggi
di happiness anno il culo troppo in là
perché se non avessero alcun operatore
vinto però vabbè però abbiamo già faccio
lo aspetta fermi questa è una provata
allucinante
proprio lui incredibile stavo dicendo
abbiamo appurato dall'ultimo episodio
che effettivamente la grafica di
attivisti nel tempo si è macchiata ma
non si è capito per quale motivo cioè se
guardate primis si vede peggio e questa
cosa qua anche nello scorso episodi così
non si sa per celano l'anno peggiorata è
l'unico gioco che dopo il 10 anni che
esiste è riuscito a peggiorare la
grafica c'è questa cosa non ha senso
dai il quarto tempo per vincere a
sventare
e beh ma piuttosto di così il salto non
lo posso fare a meno che non ti stacchi
adesso
ti prego
dai
eravamo cento per cento passi io a me
non sembra cento per cento pozzi ma
anche se faccio un salto minimo come
diavolo ci arrivo fin giù
è troppo dritto lo devi fare dovevi fare
tipo un imbuto spy phone sono non cadi
buono buono
madonna che tattica che tattica
praticamente mi ha rimandato indietro
l'affare cioè il segue è stato
fighissimo oltre che facciamo molto
difficile anche se ormai non c'è nulla
difficile anzi potete vedere la mia
vittoria istantanea
poté vedere una vittoria istantanea
la mia vittoria è stata la mia vittoria
istantanea sonora evidente farle per
favore per la questa frase detta da un
maschio lei stesa gay devono bloccare la
vita è impossibile attenzione
che culo era oggi abbiamo fatti tutti i
ragazzi ci manca solo su altro ecco i
classici abbiamo fatti tutti manca solo
un imposti col anzi l'abbiamo fatto
anche quello come primo
perfetto adesso voi mi spiegate come in
un rock swing io possa aver perso la
testa che non esiste cioè posso perdere
tutto ma non la mia testa in un rock
swing al massimo le braccia la testa
come
allora green screen
all right
non è vero ma l'ho visto saltato
incredibile non so come vorrei che gli
sono dondolare zio non so come fare
neanche questo
madonna
limite c'è un passaggio anche se vado
dritto da qua in qualche modo
mi sa di no secondo me i ragazzi rossini
sono sempre stati molto difficile solo
che sono molto sottovalutati c'è un
livello di camera o se io che non ero
romney che quasi quasi come di
impossible lo stesso riggio anzi forse
ci mette o meno tempo a fare un
impossibile che un rock swing
come come come come come successa quel
come possibile a chi è saltato l'elmetto
tutto a posto ma da oggi ho fatto due
ore per fare sta roba poi la prima è
riuscito poi ero incastrato con la testa
non sono che come incredibile
incredibile texture play cavallo che
chiedo che il culo a barre perfetto
perfetto
madonna difficilissimo è stato salivari
sua short di cosa embed et making rock
swing va bene i'm dead to play rock
swing fratello personali psi però
aumenti e veloci questo finale che palle
quanto tempo per è ovvio in join us si
sia sei stato molto bravo 013 e uno che
è più l'isola provato per la prima volta
adesso oyeah
perfetto la testata finale ci sta con
questo livello difficilissimo walk
through rock così abbiamo unito tutto
rock kings
la zia lo zio il prozio
il nonno auguro ha dato più 3 spazio che
perfetto quello mancato quello l'ho
presa non lo volevo prendere
che se c'è
sono morto perché cascata una squadra
qua sotto va bene tieni non ottieni
panel uk vieni tutti arco demonio non
aspettavo ma torna che chi l'ho fatto
rob singh per sbloccare un affido perché
letizia ok perfetto non so se adesso ci
sono spalle di torino ok oggi si faccia
a cazzotti co housing 15 ho paura
effettivamente però proviamo lo stesso e
poi dieci secondi e la madonna che è un
lancio della nasa dopo tuma c 10 secondi
non lo so
bellissimo giubbotto magia staff a giro
che non si vede sembra essere in matrix
va avere madonna e rave quanto ho fatto
forte che cazzo sono finiti
quanto culo quanto culo in una sola
persona quanto quello che botte di culo
sorega sarà yepes che vi vuole premiare
perché ci ho giocato per anni quando
nessuno lo avrebbe mai fatto prova flyng
su al decrescere
ah ok che vede crescere ho capito cosa
facciamo hard subito se tu devi andare
velocissimo prima che ti spacca il coso
c'è veramente assurdo
veloce e lo zio madonna e sono
incastrato poche ferite
oggi riesce subito a madonna mi
assomiglia e nardò tra l'altro senza
neanche provare gli altri così l'ex co
boy ma tom bol foglio una botta che non
lo faccio ball force sono quelli dove
devi schivare le palle per tre casi c'è
un bordello il golfo sorta di un
bordello
anche se non sembra perché di ricadere
in un certo modo è un casino il bowl for
effettivamente orari ci penso
gary gross con il piedino rimasto lì c'è
qualche impossible che li possiamo hanno
fattivamente noi death and blood sangue
e morte era livello family friendly
quindi va bene
[Musica]
credo credo quando entra un moscerino
nella stanza e non capisci dove
personalizzato grazie
non si è capito una una sega ma va bene
ragazzi c'è l'importante è finire il
gioco spy fall monsters co 2 min
avevo un mostro risp iphone
ma cos'è starà a devo entrare in gol all
origine
ok nomi deglutì ningyo [ __ ] miglior
tiscione è come si sa ok dovevo farmi
spazio io
molto carino molto bene sono tutti molto
semplice sono io che sono ultra bravo
oggi non lo so per concludere raga mi
farei un imposti colma di quelli
veramente complicati se si può fare
vediamo uno che superiorità tipo questi
il prossimo il poco 2 bene
effettivamente un po di kakà ce l'aveva
ma mai dire mai provi a pro sempre
provare ragazzi
ok quindi l'obiettivo era era a
fuorviare i razzi madonna sono vivo
questa questo è stato bellissimo questo
è stato sicuramente meglio di quella di
primo non solo com era stato i crediti
cook e ragazzi oggi solo vittorie e che
vittorie se posso essere sincero
ceramente in credito ci aveva dato
proprio bene non succede mai però aveva
intanto successo signori spero che vi
sia piaciuto questa la fps giudei e
lasciato momento mi piace se non siano
questi schietti ragazzine come sempre ci
vediamo al prossimo video beh ragazzi
[Musica]